hey everybody John Luke here we're gonna
be doing a rage 2 trailer breakdown I
got my notes I've done some research
it's been a while since I've played the
original rage but I think I've got
everything in order so let's get to this
okay so first off we see this
interesting power being used here where
you're using your hand here to launch
this guy in the air we see this a couple
other times later in the trailer so
we'll talk about more then the other
thing you'll notice is the pistol it is
different from the other pistol in the
first game so looks like we're now some
sort of new weapons and of course
immediately after that we see some
driving this one's gonna have more of an
emphasis on that it's gonna be
open-world and look at that there's
green there's other things than brown in
this one so already a good sign all
right here we see the shotgun it looks
very similar and designed to the combat
shotgun from the original slightly
tweaked seems like it's probably gonna
be pretty similar alright and then here
we see this massive mutant enemy pretty
similar to the authority mutants from
the first game but looks a lot bigger so
I imagine you can seem like a pretty big
focus based on the trailer for this I
would say here we're just getting some
environmental shots of the world and
something I really like here is that
there's a lot more color to this one the
original game was sort of going for that
Mad Max vibe and that's all well and
good but it was a little dull it could
have used more colour more pop and they
definitely seem to be doing that I'm
actually getting tanker vibes off of
this one which is a pretty excellent
comic if you've never read it and a
terrible terrible movie so don't watch
that another thing to note is the rifle
on the back of this woman is the
authority machine gun from the first
game so it seems like that weapon will
also be making a return okay so here
we're getting some more environmental
shots we got a forest we got this hazy
yellow field and we got this forest in
the dark
I like the emphasis on lush environments
and this trailer really seems like
they're stepping it up compared to the
first game and this shot here in the
dark kind of shows that where it's
probably gonna be a day/night cycle I
think that's a pretty safe bet pretty
much every open world at this point has
one of those never getting more of the
authority looking mutants really leaning
into that sort of like doom revenant
looking vibe I'm pretty into that I
think that was probably the most unique
part of the original game was the enemy
design so I'm kind of glad to see
they're carrying that forward alright so
this is a shot that's easy to miss but I
really love this creepy looking mutant
with the glowing eyes here in this
forest I've actually recently been
playing the forest the video game and
I love that game and this has given me
some of those vibes in fact I'd really
love this game had some of those more
kind of creepy moments maybe balance out
the the wacky over-the-top tone could be
pretty fun it was yours for the taking
so here we have the same combat shotgun
from earlier but now it has been painted
with different colors I think in this
could either be two things either this
is a weapon picked up from a particular
Raider faction and the Raiders will
paint the guns based on their own colors
or the game's gonna have a larger
customization for your weapons mod skins
that kind of thing I'm hoping it's the
latter I think that'd be really cool the
player here also seems to be
participating in some sort of minigame
where you shoot mutants out of a cannon
which is all sorts of messed up but
really fits with the more
tongue-in-cheek vibe they seem to be
going for so this guy's armor design is
new it wasn't in the previous game but
he still looks like he could be an
authority soldier seems like the
authority are still gonna play a pretty
major role in this game if you're not
familiar with the first rage they were
sort of the primary antagonist in that
game ended on a really bad cliffhanger
which implied you were gonna have to
fight them more so seems logical that
they would be in this game as well this
guy here looks like a pretty cool enemy
to fight and my hope is that we
eventually get to control one of these
bad boys because that would be rad
okay so now we're finally getting into
some combat the weapon here seems new
could be a redesign of the authority
machine gun but it does look different
from the one that was on that woman's
back earlier in the trailer so might be
a new gun altogether not sure
and then we see here this melee attack
sent some sort of pulse wave that just
completely eviscerated these dudes this
animation is pretty similar to the bit
we saw at the beginning which makes me
believe it is the same thing seems like
it's some sort of a tech melee power you
have equipped and here we see the wing
stick from the first game makers return
cutting that dude's head off just like
it did in the original I like the wing
stick well enough I think it was one of
the more iconic elements from the
original rage but I would like to see it
expanded upon in this one hopefully they
can make it even more satisfying this
time and here's the part where they let
you know that the game is in fact
open-world its 2018 every game has to be
open-world at this point I'm poking a
little fun but honestly I think it does
make sense the original games open-world
elements were pretty shallow and I think
this one could really expand from a
proper open-world especially since
Avalanche is making this game I think
they make really good open worlds and
I'm really excited to see how they
combine that with its shooting I think
that could be a pretty good combination
so at first I thought this guy was
rocket jumping which I was actually
really excited about but then it turns
out he's using his hand to launch
himself up in the air it seems to be the
same animation he was using to Visser 8
those dudes with that pulse so it seems
like that ability has multiple
applications you can use it to jump up
in the air you can use it to kill dude
seems like it's gonna be a pretty
versatile tool I also want to say I'm
really loving the added mobility we're
seeing right here in this combat the
original game was pretty grounded and
slow and kind of like that Ede fast feel
and this seems like they're kind of more
going for that and I am all for that
and here we see you're doing a ground
slam around enemy rides me of the
Spartan ability in Halo 5 I'm wondering
if this is part of the same power you
can use that pulse power or if it's
something else entirely I don't know if
you're swapping between the abilities or
it's all just the same ability that you
can use in different circumstances for
now it's hard to tell but it seems like
those abilities on your left hand are
gonna be a pretty major part of combat I
also really like this part here you're
gonna get in this really chaotic
open-world combat here that was really
something the first game never did great
most the combat was in indoor areas and
the outside was really meant more for
vehicle combat so seeing all these
enemies run around vehicles in the mix
just seems like really chaotic and messy
in a way that I'm really excited for
reminds me of games like Just Cause
which of course Avalanche made so it
makes sense overall I'm really liking
the direction they're going with the
combat
and that was trailer for age two I got
to say it's leaving me pretty optimistic
first Ridge is a totally okay game but
there's nothing about it that made me
remember it past a couple weeks this
seems like they're taking some of the
criticisms about that games blandness to
heart and seem to be injecting a lot
more energy into it and I'm really
excited to see more of this in action
which I imagine we will at e3
all right everybody thank you for
watching this trailer breakdown if I
missed anything let me know in the
comments and have a wonderful day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]